[Music]
you know those pit crews you see in
NASCAR races that rush out and change
the tires and stuff I decided to hire my
own fourth of July
decorations pit crew to decorate my desk
you want to see how fast they can do
this
[Applause]
[Applause]
you turned into an Allman brother you
look like one of the Allman Brothers
right now this is fantastic
now I'm in the mood what do you don't
that's not I'm looking this hotdog
angler you're not people bite into it'll
be like that taste it's sparkly yeah I
like there's just an orange flashlight
underneath that right now all right well
as you can see fourth of July fake
that's show business ladies and
gentlemen however there is real mustard
that's real
we're on eat it'll be good are you
kidding
[Applause]
there may be a really good reason why
he's not eating it that might be a prize
that was cooked during the Gerald Ford
admit I mean sure you're all you're all
putting this peer pressure on me but I'm
gonna be the one with the diarrhea yeah
so forget it why should this fourth of
July be any different they don't know
that
you